les sambas seuls 7 décembre 1941 les
japonais attaquent la base de pearl
harbour
les américaines n'ont rien vu venir
l'année suivante il crée le ss office
stratégique sauver ce qui deviendra
sourire truman en 1947 la cia
intelligence agency une agence civile
s'attache recueillir évaluer des
renseignements sensibles pour la
sécurité nationale à la demande et pour
l' usage du président des états unis la
cia son siège à l'anglais au nord-ouest
de washington probablement l'édifice de
mieux gardés du monde
plus de 20000 employés et un budget
annuel de plus de 12 milliards de
dollars
cette vidéo de la cia présente ses
principaux services celui des opérations
clandestines
c'est à ces espions qu'on pense quand on
parle de la cia et c'est ce qu'on voit
au cinéma à la télé il ya aussi les
opérations spéciales sous les ordres du
président comme l'exécution d'oussama
ben laden en 2011 où les bombardements
par drones
moins réussi l'invasion ratée de la baie
des cochons en 1961 sous crédit de même
que les nombreuses tentatives
d'assassinât de fidel castro qui mourra
de sa belle mort succès par contre des
coups d'état au guatemala ou chili en
1973 les autres services sont moins
spectaculaires la cia recruté
techniciens des ingénieurs des juristes
des analystes car elle doit recueillir
des informations sur tous par tous les
moyens légaux ou illégaux des
informations pour que le président
puisse prévoir les crises et les
confrontations
ça n'a pas toujours fonctionné la cia
prévoit la guerre israélo arabe des six
jours
mais pas celle de 1973 elle ne voit pas
venir la chute du shah d'iran 1978 et la
révolution islamiste ni l'invasion de
l'afghanistan par l'urss
pire encore ils surestiment l'arsenal
soviétique et ne croit pas à la chute du
mur de berlin et de l' empire soviétique
en 1991
enfin elle ne voit pas venir les
attentats du 11 septembre 2001 sous
george w bush la cia est autorisé à
diriger des centres d'interrogation de
présumés terroristes à guantanamo en
afghanistan et en irak où se pratique la
torture au cours des ses 70 ans
d'histoire
la cei a certainement connu des succès
mais à cause du caractère fondamental de
ces opérations
ils sont restés secrets jean michel le
bras sera du canada à montréal